though because i had mark normand here
um on my mark's great mark's great but
now again mark is a real comic and and
mark was not on social media mark is a
guy who came up doing five sets tonight
in new york city yes and that's my
question is because i even asked him
because he's been stefano he's been on
rogan multiple times mark norman right
killer and i said like would you want
what rogan's got i don't want all that
drama i don't want a hundred million
bucks i just want to do comedy that's
all i just want to be a comedian yeah
but we talked about basically
you know the calends of the world the
rogues of the world have been doing
comedy professionally for 20-plus years
pre-social media and basically kind of
like the tick talkers of the world
and i think this guy's funny trevor
wallace but like
you know basically tick-tock instagram
influencers and ultimately my question
is is uh the barrier to entry the
barrier to entry was so freaking great
when you started you had to compete and
compete and be the best comedian in your
city in your city and then go now the
bear to entry is you can edit and do a
video i don't care it that never bothers
me i love that people are gonna make
money now and stuff i never worry about
that stuff it's like for me it's like
boxing okay or fighting okay
you might hit mitts really well dude
that's great you might even jump around
a gym with a bunch of non-boxers and you
know okay
you go to a boxing the boxers who are in
it boxers or mma guys who spar and who
are at the top of the game who can
adjust hey that has to be earned you got
to do it wrong for a long time before
you do it right
they know it and everybody else around
them knows it you know it's like
whoever like that's why eddie hearn all
due respect to jake um paul i i respect
him i think this kid is actually i mean
you can you you can criticize him all
you want he and his brother
are
hard working guys they work really hard
and hey they're putting themselves in
there you get in the ring and stuff now
now
jake i promise you in knows that's why
when he has these conversations with
eddie eddie he's like i got guys that'll
light you up well okay yeah because
those guys have been throwing a right
hand since they were seven yeah
you know so there are no shortcuts in
life there are no shortcuts in life
that's that's if i write a self-help
book please buy it it's going to be
probably one page
it's going to be one page it's going to
say it takes forever
that's forever put in the world
i do it every day so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]